все спочатку я кажу Та як діти вчаться
ходити Отто зараз так получається що я
от зараз начинаю вчитися в сопонові Я не
знаю як жити от реально я не знаю вийти
на прогулянку містом Здавалося б буденна
справа але для Андрія захтея справжня
розкіш і водночас Випробування я мерзну
сильно в мене От все ну отте руки по
відбивані в мене вони постійно холодні і
затікають постійно то маю з тим маю таку
дійсно таку серйозну проблему То факт І
вже що я не пробував так на якийсь час
от зараз капельниці прокапав трошки
легше майже с років Андрій захтей
просидів у російській в'язниці його
затримали у серпні 2016 в тимчасово
окупованому Криму тоді на півострів
зайшла українська диверсійна група у
складі якої був і нинішній очільник
Української розвідки Кирило буданов з
боями їм вдалося покинути Крим коли
Богданов публічно вже сказав про цю
спецоперацію тепер я можу сказати що я
став учасником якоїсь Скажем так
спецоперації Я не люблю то слово тому що
я не є спец і такі громкі слова ну поміг
людям чим зміг у секретній операції
деталі якої не розкривали роками Андрій
захтейв відповідав за логістику скількох
російських силовиків тоді вдалося
поранити і вбити досі достеменно
невідомо жорстко били дуже все жорстко
було дуже жорстко все було говорю та як
є дуже жорстко було не було там ніхто
тамм не гладив по голові і так далі ми
прикиньте перестріляли фсбешників мене
одного взяли можете собі представити що
вони зі мною робили там купа трупів і
нікого не взяли група уйшла взяликогось
Андрюху там відповідав за якісь
конкретні дії Андрюха поняття немає
що прошов тому що Андрій не задає довних
питань По телефону із моменту затримання
каже Андрій захтей почався найжахливіший
період його життя оговтатися після якого
не може й досі хоча в Україну колишній
політв'язень повернувся майже півроку
тому перші дні
то Зрозуміло підвали
ФСБ потім на
неділю я заїхав в сімферопольське СІЗО
тоже так якби сидів в таких відділеннях
як карцер отдельно тримали бо не знали
куда садити Ну все
потім вертольот летимо морем в
Ростов потім в машину іліфортова фсбшна
тюрма потім там потім звід там назад в
Крим опять в тюрму місцеву під час
ув'язнення Андрій зяхтей зазнавав
найрізноманітніших тортур можуть так
прийти молоді Курсанти скажемо назвем їх
так фсбшні голови відкрити YouTube
подивитися якісь спитки помто на топі
попробувати Ну а чого ні І сидять тоже
то знімають собі на пам'ять Утім
найжахливішим каже було катування
струмом заходиш стіл вот фонар от там
машинка стоїть даже перед тобою То що
ток п'є по тобі і ніхто не
ховає ти заходиш Ти понімаєш що перед
тобою і дві клеми як до акумулятора Ну
от підцепили і давай до геніталій до
задниці до чого угодно Ліпше би
били Если би били просто палкою там чи
кулаками то і одне тебе гасять током
пару днів підряд Ну повірте мені що
згадаєш все Та попри усі знущання Андрію
захтею вдалося витримати ув'язнення і не
зійти з розуму треба мати розуміння
по-перше куда ти
попав якщо ти думаєш що ти в якийсь
фільм пав Ну то вже тоє твоя перша
помилка
друге ти мусиш показати себе тому що
розумієш тюрма то є зовсім інакше То Ну
як як країна в країні свої правила свої
закони свій Цар і так дальше Ну то же
саме тільки все в маленькому виді
попадаючи туда в першу чергу треба
розуміти як ти себе вести будеш ким ти
жити там будеш людина така существо що
ти все равно будеш виживати повір будеш
виживати ікуди ти не
дінешся каже за гратами кожен рятується
по-різному хтось починає писати хтось
поринає у читання проте основне за що
тримаються в неволі Надія ти живеш
Надією де би ти там не попав як би тобі
там тяжко не було все рівно настає вже
знаєш такий період Ну ти просто вже
привикаєш все що вот это камера
що вот это во так що воно кожний божий
день во так Воно по-інакшому не буде я
дитину свою не бачив вонародилась їй
півроку було і все мене посадили я я жив
тим моментом що я вона мене чекає що
вона мене не бачила даже ну реально даже
поняття немає тільки на фотографії на
відео і по телевізорі але запорука
виживання у російській тюрмі не
створювати проблем для її адміністрації
пояснює Андрій захтей особливо це
стосується політв'язнів адже про них
часто пишуть українські та іноземні
видання а це зайвий клоп для керівництва
буцигарні Якщо там буде написано там
Андрій сидить в колонії к номер оди
міста Сімферополя наш полідв'язнь
тратататата то є одне ну коли будуть
писати Що тебе там б'ють і ще щось І
п'яти дете їсти не дають і таблеток не
дають все Ти создаєш
проблему все Ну зовсім по-інакшому йде
розмова розумієш коли ти дав якесь слово
і тобто на якісь певні речі Вони
закривають очі бо закривають очі якщо ти
наприклад говориш про колонію Я писати
не
буду А ви що мені начинаєш торги тому що
тобі треба там жити у лютому Андрія
захтея звільнили з колонії проте
російська влада не дозволила йому
виїхати в Україну і помістила до центру
тимчасового утримання іноземних громадян
у Ростовській області а згодом забрали
всі документи аби колишній політв'язень
не зміг перетнути кордон і повернутися в
Україну у мене деже забрали справку об
освобождение що щоб мене Латвія не
пустила Ну все зробили для того щоб не
пустили не додумалися що в мене в сумці
двойне дно а там всі копії всіх моїх
документів повністю збережені в файлі І
все я сумку розриваю на границі дістаю
копії ставлю в
пограничник люди тебе там чекають раз
прозріли що
прощолкала Утім навіть після звільнення
боротьба за життя триває перебування за
гратами сильно підірвало здоров'я що я
там зробив гепатит С хронічний аж
зробився
хронічним потім хронічний простатит від
бетону зробився
хронічним гастрити там Слава Богу язва
як такої нема нога стріти є руки
повідбивані сухожиля не ну все Шрам тіки
в наручниках били товкли руки не міють
розумієте Пина болить ну купа проблем ну
крім того через катування струмом Андрій
захтей втратив 18 зубів То що було
давнодавно в 2016
році то було на ліфортовсько на
ліфортову на фсбшній тюрмі короче мене
щось зуб болів Ну там була жінка одна і
вона коли робила мені снімок От этим
ультрафіолетом вона мені зразу сказалаже
питкиток Я кажу Дана каже все зуби
улетять Я кажу чо вони всі мікротріщини
получили коли за макушки вуха плюс-мінус
ну все воно ж то кудою
проходить все все почало сипатись каже
Лише на протезування зубів пішло 190 000
грн А на боротьбу з іншими хворобами
знадобляться мільйони приміром взятися
за лікування гепатиту готові в Німеччині
але вартість курсу сягає 40 тися євро
розповідає колишній політв'язень тож
через брак коштів вирішення проблем зі
здоров'ям відкладає на потім мені брат
трошечки поміг грошима То я проколовся
проколов
трошечки вот это почистив вени трошки
серце і для того щоб печінку ВТА попав
трошки капельниці собі поробив Так ти
мене вибач дружина зайшла в аптеку
купила на п 5ть днів капальниць Купила
таблетки для сну тому що що я без них не
сплю я без таблеток взагалі не сплю Я
сплю пару годин ну на нервовій системі
Так вона 4500 лишила за
капельниці так А де уколи А де все
остальне і взятися за якесь лікування і
думати мені сьогодні хватило завтра не
хватило то ліпше взагалі нічого не
начинати бо тому що хіба гірше зробиш
тож нині Андрій захтей просить всіх
небайдужих допомогти зі збором коштів на
лікування адже найбільше мріє
повернутися до нормального життя треба
Ну що розвиватися дальше щось думати я ж
кажу мені в мене дитина в другому класі
мені треба кормити мені треба Ну жити
далі
[музика]
надо